Salut! On va commencer la vidéo par un petit rituel qu'on va tenir sur les 31 prochains jours :
Je vous donne d'abord la solution de l'énigme de la veille.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier avec l'énigme d'hier, regardez la tout de suite parce que maintenant je vais donner la réponse.
Pour trouver la réponse il fallait simplement retourner le dessin des places de parking.
Et la on se rend compte que c'est pas les places 16, 06, 68, ...
Mais les places 86, 87, 88, 89, ...
Donc la voiture se gare sur la place n°87 !
C'était donc ça et je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous l'on trouvé.
Et donc nouvelle énigme, la n°2 !
On est Samedi et de temps en temps le samedi je vous ferez plutôt un défi
Genre un défi qu'on peut faire dans un bar pour ce faire payer un coup ou un défi à faire à un repas.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est le cas. C'est un Samedi-défi !
Vous demandez à quelqu'un de mettre une pièce de monnaie sur la table et de recouvrir la pièce avec une tasse opaque. Comme ceci.
Et vous annoncez que vous allez être capable de récupérer la pièce de monnaie dans votre main sans que vous ne touchiez jamais la tasse.
En clair vous ne toucherai jamais la tasse.
Même par contact indirect !
C'est à dire que vous n'avez pas le droit de prendre 2 objets pour soulever la tasse par exemple.
Vous ne toucherais jamais la tasse et pourtant, vous aller être capable de récupérer la pièce.
Cherchez bien comment réaliser ce défi. Y'a une solution qui existe et qui est efficace dans 100% des cas.
J'ai moi-même bu quelques bières à l’œil grâce à ce défi!
Si vous avez trouver la réponse, surtout ne la mettez pas dans les commentaires !
Vous pouvez en parler mais ne mettez pas la réponse, laissez les autres chercher.
Par contre dès que vous avez trouvé la solution mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on puisse voir le pourcentage de personnes qui ont trouvé la solution par rapport au nombre de vues
Profitez du soleil et passez un bel été !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir parce que le mental vlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !
Donc rendez vous demain à 11h. Ciao !